we actually have a much better education
system in Illinois than they have true
in Florida we're ranked higher than they
are yes U.S news and World Report ranks
K-12 education in Illinois sixth in the
country and number one among the largest
states in the country yeah
so he's got nothing to brag about when
it comes to education so uh so he moves
on and tries to use this word woke to
describe everything he doesn't even know
what the word means and he has no
definition of it it's just anything he
doesn't like is wokism true and all I
can tell you is that I don't know what
that means and frankly uh what I can say
about Illinois is that we're a state
that cares about Equity or a state that
cares about our families that's woke
caring about your family and Equity
that's what he means by woke sir